fascinating reporting here that he
approached that musk approached Paige
about selling the company how serious
were these talks Ashley well you know it
got pretty serious I mean Tesla had been
it was in this interesting spot it had
gotten some really good reviews on the
model acid had been out for about six
months but there were all these
customers who were lined up they were in
order to buy the in line to buy the car
and they'd offered to do these pre-sales
but they weren't committing to doing the
sales and Tesla was running out of money
and Elon had to kind of come up with a
plan to save the company just in case it
went under right so people don't realize
at the time so you're talking around
2012 2013 so they had these pre-orders
but as you just said Ashley they were
having trouble the company was having
trouble actually sealing the deal on
these orders right I mean you detail how
must what called in the heads of all of
his departments and said you've got to
close each of these orders right yeah I
mean you know there were the early
adopters who sort of wanted a computer
on wheels and and they were out there
buying the car the rest of the people
were waiting on the sidelines a bit and
you know some of the early model asses
had glitches with the door handles or
the windshield wipers sort of working
out the kinks and so I think people were
also waiting for new colors and software
updates and so this is what really was
kind of punishing the company and when
Elon found out about it I think the
executives had tried to you know hide it
not what Elon know exactly how severe it
was for a little while and then what he
found out he sort of turned the whole
company around to go sell these cars and
then ring ringing he calls Larry Page
and what did what is the deal that he
exactly tried to work out with him at
Google well it's an interesting day I
mean he wanted he wanted Google to buy
Tesla and then he also wanted these
guarantees he wanted about five billion
dollars that Google would put towards
Tesla's factories and making sure that
the Model S and future cars came out and
man Elon also wanted to guarantee that
Tesla got this third generation car that
they're working on out he it's going to
be more around $35,000 right so he
wanted to stay at the company for eight
years right under Google so
willing to work at Google under Larry
Page yeah because you know for Elon this
third-generation car is sort of his one
of his big callings in life and he was
worried that Google might be into
bringing that car to market initially
and then back out later on and so he
wanted to be there personally to be sure
that it came to fruition I just want to
tell people the numbers okay so he was
willing to sell the company at six
billion dollars right Ashley he wanted
five billion dollars for factory
expansion Tesla now though market cap
twenty six billion dollars so I of
course it ended up being the right
decision for must to not sell to Google
and to continue on as an independent now
for Tesla now is there still an option
for them to be sold I mean what's the
buzz now you know I mean it's funny
because all the rumors to date have been
around Apple bike Tesla and as far as I
know you know I mean those discussions
really haven't come anywhere close to
this sort of thing and everyone's kind
of missed on the Google part Tesla
doesn't really need to sell as much
anymore I mean they're able to raise
capital for all these ambitious things
they're doing with the battery factory
their stock price is still high enough
they look healthy Elon has enough money
on his own you know I think I think the
only reason I really think that they
would sell is if Elon felt that the
company was at this really solid point
and he wanted to devote more attention
to space axon and some of his other
pursuits and felt like you know he could
put it in someone else's hands and they
would bring a mainstream electric car to
market but that was sort of like need to
sell to keep the company alive it's a
different place now